نعم محمد قبل قليل كانت مروحيتان عسكريتان
اسرائيليتان تتمركز قباله المنطقه الغربيه
من من مدينه رفح قباله ساحل مدينه رفح
اطلقت قبل قليل سارو خين على الاقل
بالاضافه الى اطلاقات من الرشاشات الثقيله
اتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه
خان يونس ولم نعرف طبيعه الاهداف التي
تستهدفها هذه المروحيات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تتمركز قباله شاطئ مدينه
رفح وتستهدف المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه خانيونس و والان نسمع تحليق هذه
الطائرات هذه المنطقه تحديدا الجنوبيه
الغربيه بمدينه خنوس تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه
عنيفه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى عدد من
المناطق التي تتوغل فيها اليات ودبابات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه خان
يونس يتزامن ذلك مع الاعلان قبل قليل عن
استشهاد ثلاثه من الفلسطينيين اثر قصف
اسرائيلي على منطقتي الفخاري وايضا منطقه
الشيخ ناصر في المدينه
وايضا تمكن طواقم الاسعاف قبل قليل من
انتشال جثامين اربعه من الشهداء من منطقه
المواصي كانوا قد استشهدوا نتيجه قصف
اسرائيلي والان تطلق الطائرات المروحيه
الاسرائيليه صاروخا جديدا تجاه المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه من المدينه كل هذه
التطورات والاشتباكات وايضا تدخل الطيران
المروحي تحديدا في هذه المنطقه يتزامن مع
استمرار الغارات الاسرائيليه الكثيفه
تحديدا على منطقه وسط وجنوب مدينه خانيونس
بالاضافه الى المنطقه الشرقيه والتي شنت
مقاتلات حربيه اسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات
الجويه منذ ساعات الصباح وحتى هذه اللحظه
دمرت خلالها منازل سكنيه سواء في قيزان
رشوان وقز النجار وايضا جوره العقاد ومحيط
المستشفى الاوروبي بالاضافه الى منطقه
البلد
التي تستهدفها بشكل دائم ومستمر طائرات
جيش الاحتلال وتشهد اشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
امتدادا الى منطقه شارع القص وشارع خمسه
التي تتمركز فيها اليات جيش الاحتلال
اوضاع انسانيه صعبه داخل مدينه خان يونس
رغم اعاده انتشار جيش الاحتلال وانسحابه
من بعض المناطق لكنه يتوغل في مناطق اخرى
تشهد قصفا مدفعيا وغارات جويه وايضا
اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عموم المناطق التي
تتوغل فيها اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال
المنطقه الشرقيه وايضا الجنوبيه الغربيه
والشماليه الغربيه وايضا في محيط منطقه
البلد وحي الامل الذي لازال يشهد قصفا
وغارات اسرائيليه وايضا استهدافا مباشرا
لمستشفى الامل من قبل دبابات جيش الاحتلال
ومنع سيارات الاسعاف من الخروج من هذا
المستشفى لانتشال جثامين الشهداء من
المناطق القريبه وايضا انقاذ حياه الجرحه
ونقلهم الى مجمع ناصر الطبي شكرا جذ لك
مؤمن الشرافي من رفح